[Music]
you
hey to mr. Monson you understand you're
trespassing right now right I have an
easier with the previous owner of your
property previous being the operative
word who's this the guy cool you could
get back to your nice truck go play okie
[__] tomorrow I call looks like mr.
Boggs and iris and muscle looks that way
it's a friend of mine from with a big
mouth I hear that a lot and you probably
hear this too more than I'd like and you
know the grill i'ma count three and
you're going to start walking away our
rights to this one have a lawyer now 23
know the drill yeah
amir available until about you see I
have fun lauren cash boy jumping port
services people
hello you know you gotta pay for that
right hey not okay we got ourselves an
excellent fan maybe a quarter of it
happens and not like this in the real
world people die Logan I don't want to
talk about it Logan just stop be careful
I need the girl Walker oh come here
[Music]
no no no and we're down
oh she's like you oh very much like you
no I'm not whatever it is you think I am
we talked she needs our help
on come on someone has come along well
this is what life looks like
it will love each other
he should take a moment
healer
still have time
[Music]
you
Logan who did you to turn off the world
is not the same as a watch
you
the Ghana I hurt myself today to see if
I still feel I focus on the thing the
only thing that's real machine they need
the things like you of time very much
like you feeling this is here gdial you
are come along everyone has come along I
am still right here and you could
is all
I invite
[Music]
I will let you
I would find a way noggin still have
time
[Music]
Oh
wheel or my name is look I may be able
to help you find someone I'm not
specially I come with you I'm coming
flood the UN so long they do what you
need to do no code of conduct unto death
you are so you're sure they did to me
what I am it can't be undone yes
different now it can't hurt you a lot of
people have tried to kill me I'm still
here
you have a thread good Longley enough of
all right now I'm feeling unbelievable
gratitude that this pot happened to come
into my life what you have with
Wolverines backstory and an actor of
power hugh jackman playing in is unique
among other superhero film Wolverine and
Hugh Jackman cannot now separate the man
and the road have merged
he's found a way to connect a deep part
of himself to this character lay down a
few jasmine is going to be my last time
up here on the claws one last
this is what life looks like feel it in
that time what's so wonderful not you is
that he hungry to go deeper and darker
and he's ever been before because this
is used last movie as this character I
wanted to make sure not that it's his
last movie but that it is best
and cut we got it the really surreal day
I've got my 16 year old in the trailer
who was not even born when I started
playing this oh no movie has meant more
to me than this movie when the bottom of
my heart thank you so much for helping
us realize it's true I am grateful good
thing you know the people and I consider
it a great great privilege to have had
the chance to play this character
[Music]